hello and welcome to this video playing
respect I guy and this is the guy that
lost against a couple of games ago from
that wacky Kings Indian where I was up a
million points or whatever it was so I
hope I'm doing better this time I mean I
did well in the game originally but then
um yeah then I gave it all the way okay
I don't really remember the precise
details yeah so we'll see do I go queen
85 I think I think I tried all this in
earlier game and it didn't work out so
well I think I'll go for the whole the
Hedgehog
interesting tries to go into d6d 696
look 28 yep should work what does he
have some wacky tactic I don't see it
nope don't see don't see anything
the interesting point about this
Hedgehog is that which is what is
different let's say to other forms of
the setup is that here I've got the
payoff bishops and this is quite helpful
because the position usually opens up
later and then especially the dark
squared Bishop can be a very valuable
piece okay so Bishop d7 f4 is that
dangerous don't know f 1 96 f 5 95 and
96 c scott night 96 you might have 95
ticks ticks going to be 6d takes pawn
takes now that works it looks a bit
looks a bit loose but it does work okay
i also have to go back f5 i also can go
to f8 maybe i should go to f8 yeah okay
it was a pretty loosening idea anyway f5
I mean we went to put this though i
don'ti 6 doesn't do much let's go back
oh it's a nice shot
it's a nice short
okay and I couldn't take cause of 95
Jack and this this means he is getting
my bishop it's not not ideal to say the
least oh I don't have this that's a
pretzel that's bad ok after prevent 93
for the time being know that this is
good news is weakening himself without
any any clear purpose we wants to go to
defy for a couple of interesting things
now I can also go here let's go there
let's try to open it up a little bit
yam this is probably not a bad a bad
choice trying to trade stuff as this
king is potentially some wood week yeah
chat
maybe rip c4 hmmmm maybe it's kind of
looks you for coming not not totally
sure here Roxy 7 is not a big deal yeah
this one has a moral problem but rook
dc-8 if i can trade one rook I'm okay
because my king defends d6 my rope would
defend before and then I mean I have
some strategic places here as well his
Bishop is not particularly fantastic so
here I will trade one Rock right no way
take the pot and it's not blunder stuff
yeah I don't know if I want to trade
whole rooks this is this is actually
probably not so timeline anyway I have
to speed up yeah maybe books e-books e8
Bishop c8 ok well let's decide don't
mind why am i doing why we are not
understanding the position correctly
should be 5 i've got 9 f8 maybe he has
something brilliant like check and night
age 6 or something I don't see it though
ah cool that's a good move good idea
Wow check it's a big check
don't really have much time here King c7
would have been good if I would have
seen that it would have trapped his rook
basically having trapping sounds Jack ah
and I didn't see the check I have five
seconds oh my god this is the real
problem I didn't I didn't look so much
at the clock yeah okay I'm losing it
sometime it doesn't make any sense black
I simply didn't look at the clock I was
too engaged in defending this position
it was probably a decent-enough defense
well it was quite kinda kind of
interesting i think a g6 and this is an
interesting move and yeah probably here
I should go King c7 yeah yeah it doesn't
really work you always retain some
pressure the way it went at least this
is an interesting idea just play for the
attack I could have started with this
move this is maybe this is this is more
precise of course this is this ship's
you for
this is actually the game it's very
close to that added here at night on f8
yeah this is distance is more precise if
you take that g6 so this and now what
you succeed I don't have the night on fa
this is just better which is better in
comparison
I think with precise play that black
should still be okay but it's very
difficult to to do that yeah white
always has this kind of pressure going
on in the Blitz game this is this is
very annoying the funny way of playing
and the pawns I don't know that the
engine is always on 000 as it sees a way
to keep l'exposition compact but it's
it's a difficult difficult play for a
human with no time on the clock that's
simply forgot the clock okay well thanks
for watching